it was a small protest due in part to
the downpour but significant is the
first since these demonstrators were
banned by the High Court from protesting
directly outside Anderton park primary a
different location but their message was
the same they don't want children being
taught about same-sex relationships
please outside the school ensured the
High Court ruling was followed after
nine weeks of noisy protests at the
school gates the head teacher had had
enough the damage that has been done to
my school my staff the children the
parents is almost immeasurable
we have psychological support in school
most days for staff I have very little
staff absence normally and there has
been a spike in the last three months of
migraines stress anxiety high blood
pressure we cannot be a primary school
that does all the lovely things that a
primary school should do if staff and
children are afraid to come to school
many protesters don't have children at
the school they claimed they're not
homophobic but listen to this man at a
meeting yesterday and they transformed
into homosexuals and I showed the
footage to the head teacher it's just
utterly ridiculous you don't transform
into a homosexual and and there's
nothing sexual about anything that goes
on in my primary school or any other
primary school in the country we don't
teach sex education here I never have so
having two mommies is not a sexual issue
it's a shock with which some people
speak about this it's pure homophobia
would you ever put this teaching on hold
if that's what it took to resolve it no
the protesters have urged their
supporters to abide by the High Court
injunction for now they've been
crowdfunding in this community to raise
funds to go to the High Court on Monday
to challenge the ruling they've made it
clear they'll do whatever it takes my at
my house on this the battle has moved
from the classroom to the courts and
both sides are prepared to fight on
Becky Johnson Sky News Birmingham